c'est devenu un rendez vous
incontournable pour beaucoup regardé le
super bowl surtout pour les publicités
les entreprises rivalisent à coups de
budget pharaonique pour produire des
annonces truffé de vedettes des
publicités qui seront diffusés au coût
d'un peu plus de 5 millions de dollars
les 30 secondes un prix qui n'a pas
augmenté depuis l'an dernier
et pour cause est ce qu'on aura encore
120 millions téléspectateurs cette année
ça reste à voir
toutes les manifestations qui ont
alimenté les débuts de match du côté de
la nfl qui ont généré d'ailleurs il faut
le reconnaître des reculs d'auditoire
importants selon les semaines de 10 à 15
à 20 % moins de téléspectateurs de plus
en plus les publicitaires attise la
curiosité en diffusant des extraits
quelques jours avant le super bowl et il
faut redoubler d'originalité pour
surprendre les bons disques et aux dons
la publicité ne sera pas diffusée
pendant le match long et chaude
une seule personne un adolescent
california air pourra la voir
et sa réaction sera diffusée sur les
réseaux sociaux
signe d'un ras-le-bol cette année
la politique semble être absente de ces
publicités et il a fallu aussi composer
avec la vague youtube oubliées donc les
femmes peu vêtues pour vendre n'importe
quoi
on jouera probablement davantage la
carte de l'humour cette année et de la
nostalgie et la beauté avec les mots et
la nostalgie c'est généralement tout le
monde et tout le monde est content a
asséné par exemple ambiance rétro avec
cindy crawford qui revient dans la
nouvelle pub de pepsi
humour aussi avec danny devito du
tournage chanceux et puis on met
l'accent sur la philanthropie dans les
pubs comme stella artois qui fait la
promotion de ce projet d'eau potable en
afrique
ces publicités au super bowl permettront
en tout cas de rapporter jusqu'à 500
millions de dollars au diffuseur nbc le
moment mais aussi de pousser à la
consommation de bière et de malbouffe ou
ce cycle 1 c'est aussi ça la mairie cus
ou pauvres
si frédéric arnold radio canada montréal
[Musique]